and baby makes three macaulay culkin and
brenda song have welcomed their first
child together
it's been incredible e.t can confirm the
couple who's been together since 2017.
welcome to baby boy dakota song culkin
he arrived last monday
weighing in at six pounds and 14 ounces
dakota is the first child of both actors
and is named in honor of makoli's sister
dakota who passed away in 2008.
in a statement to et the couple says
that they are overjoyed by their new
addition
adding mom and newborn are happy and
healthy fantastic
in 2018 mccully first spoke about his
desire to have kids with this actress
love
on the joe rogan experience i want i'm
going to make some babies you know all
that kind of stuff so again
this one so this one's a good one so you
know like i'm probably gonna put some
babies in her like in a little bit
you know i mean we've definitely been
practicing but uh yeah yeah
that's important yeah but uh but yeah no
yeah no this one like yeah i'm gonna
have a
gonna have some pretty babies i'm very
very very lucky the couple first worked
together on the set of changeland back
in 2017.
i just decided to find a life that
suited me
we spent five weeks in thailand shooting
this and this has been in the making for
the last like seven years and it was
incredible i mean it was
like change land for me that sounds
super cheesy but like i came back like a
different person
don't worry everything will be okay
e.t was the first to break the news of
their romance after they were spotted
showing pda
at knott's berry farm in 2017. flash
forward to 2019 and brenda opened up to
e.t about how she and mccully bonded
over growing up as child
stars
yay me i mean i think that's one thing
that
uh you know it's almost like child
actors we don't need to talk about you
just look each other in the eye and you
nod and we know
[Music]
you